معانا في الاستوديو ازمن خالد اهلا بك في
هذه النشره ابتداءا اذا المنيو
حد 60 دولارا كحد سعر اقصى لبرميل النفط
الروسي الهدف هو خفض عائدات روسيا من هذا
القطاع هل فعليا هناك مؤشرات على ان
العائدات ستتراجع بالفعل
من يفرض هذه العقوبه هي الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي بالاضافه الى مجموعه السابعه
يعني الولايات المتحده واليابان وكندا
وعدد من الدول الاوروبيه ومعهم استراليا
همم روسيا ستخسر الاموال لكن من صعب جدا
القول او تقييم حجم الخساره الروسيه لماذا
اولا حسنيه لابد ان نعرف انه في كل
الاحوال ايا كان السعر الذي تريد ان تبيع
به روسيا روسيا ستخسر اهم مشتري همم من
همم نفقها وهو الاتحاد الاوروبي
اهم المشترين كدول الصين لكن اهم المشترين
تكتلات اقتصاديه هو الاتحاد الاوروبي وهي
تمثل نحو 30 في المئه من صادرات النفط
الروسي الاتحاد الاوروبي اكثر من 40
بالمئه وفي كل الاحوال سبق وقرر
الاوروبيون انه بنهايه هذا العام سيقوفنا
نحو 90% من نفطه الروسي الذي كانوا
يستوردونه قبل ذلك يعني ايا كان سعر النفط
الروسي الاوروبيون يا نونا همم توقف عن
شراء نحو 90% طب ما قيمه يقوم الاتحاد
الاوروبي الان بالقول انه همم يحدد السعر
ب 60% وهو ايضا بالاساس سيتوقف عن شراء
النفط اول هناك نسبه ال 10% هذا اولا لكن
الاهم بالنسبه للسوق العالميه همم الروس
ان ارادوا ان يبيعوا نفطهم الى العالم
يحتاجون الى السفن
والعقوبات هي المفروض الذي ينقل عن طريق
السوفا تحتاج الى تامينات لكن اولا لابد
من ايجاد سفن ونحو 60% من السفن التي تنقل
النفط الروسي هي سفن اوروبيه والاوروبيين
اليوم بهذا العقوبات يمنعون سوفنهم من نقل
ال ال ال النفط الروسي طب ما المشكله
روسيا ممكن ان تلجا الى دول اخرى ليها همم
اساطير يمكن ان تعتمد عليها لكن السفن
التي تقوم بنقل البضائع والنفط تحتاج الى
التامين
والدول التي تؤمن اغلب نس- اعلى نسبه او
الدول التي تقوم بسوق التامين في العالم
هي دول مجموعه السبعه والاتحاد الاوروبي
وبالتالي سيكون على الشركه اما ان تقبل ان
تخرج الى البحار المفتوحه بدون تامين او
ان تخضع لرغبه او لهذه العقوبات هل هذا
سيمنع روسيا من بيع نفسها لا هذا سيقلص
امكانيه بيع النفط لكن هناك ما يسمى في
عالم النفط اسطول الظل هي مجموعه من السفن
سفن تحاول اخفاء هويتها
تضع اعلام دول اخرى تزور في الاوراق حتى
وهي تقوم بنقل النفط بشكل غير رسمي ان
اردت ما بين قوسين تحاول اخفاء اماكن
تواجدها بالاساس هذه هذا الاسطول هذا يعمل
مع دول تتعرض لعقبات كمزويلا كايران
واليوم يبدو انه يستعد للعمل مع روسيا
وهمم وهو السيد جورنا تتحدث انه مؤخرا
حدثت طفره او اقبال غير عادي على السفن
القديمه جدا
لاعتمادها او استخدامها فيما يسمى باسطول
الظل وهذا قد يسمح لروسيا بان تتهرب من
مثل هذه همم العقوبات لكن هل هذا سيحل
المشكله ليس بالضروره ايضا لماذا لان عدد
هذه السفن يبقى محدود حتى وان كان
بالعشرات هذه السفن في الغالب سفن قديمه
بطيئه الحركه يعني لا تكون سريعه وتلبي
حاجه روسيا في بيعه وهو روسيا من اهم
صدريه النفط في العالم ثالثا هذه السفن
لكي تنتقل من مكان الى اخر تحتاج الى
المرور
البوابات المهمه كقناه السويس وهنا سيكون
عليها ان تقدم اوراق تثبت على الاقل ان
هناك تامين وفي حال عدم عدم وجود تامين
سيكون عندها صعوبه في الحركه كل هذه
العوامل لم لن تمنع روسيا من بيع نفط لكن
ستخلصه الى حد كبير طيب ما هناك زبائن
ممكن ان يحاولوا ان يجدوا الحلول الصين
والهند الصين دائما اعتمدت مصلحتها قبل كل
شيء استغلت روسيا قبل ذلك عندما بدات
العقوبات على روسيا وضغطت لكي تحصل على
تخفيضات كبيره من اجانب روسي الهندي
يشترون اثار رخيصه والصينيون يشترون
باسعار رخيصه ومع العقوبات الجديده قد
يستزيد الضغوط ليكون هناك شراء ايضا
باسعار رخيصه وهناك العديد من الدول ان
كان همم يبدو حسب الصحف الامريكان شركات
في الامارات شركات في الصين حتى البعض
يتحدث عن السعوديه انها تقوم بشراء النفط
الروسي وتقوم بعمليه تكرير
الوقود بعد ذلك حتى الى دول اوروبيه لكن
طبعا باسعار مختلفه جدا شكرا جزيلا لك على
كل هذه المعلومات الزميل خالد العربي